thank you alejandro yes i'm here with
chakri armamediarov the new leader
of the tournament the super bad chess
classic
shaq what happened in after the fourth
round you came out like a tiger after
that
okay yeah it was the last two games it's
well i played not
i mean i mean maybe good yeah i want to
say yeah
but last two days after the rest days
we tried to find some openings idea or
also some idea
to play but is not easy we know is how
levone's
openings were strong i just want to try
to play some
chest and also maybe some
not very risky chess i mean just want to
play
some good chess and i think is
i play rookie one and it was the main
movies of queen f2
and drake and he played against carlson
and he won
in world brilliant championship of the
queen of i think we all analyzed this
move queen f2 but
rookie one is solid move but you need to
play maybe some accurately some moves
maybe some i think his main lines is
queen d4 queen b6 the same
but i mean okay black if black will play
a few moves normal and it is a
normal position for black and here yeah
what do you feel happened at this point
i think he absolutely missed uh queen b3
here he missed queen of six queen b6
bishop c6 28
i think absolutely him is uh queen
bishop c yeah
he missed his own yeah i think if not to
queen e8 his black position is very good
yeah is made i think it's just miss
bishop c6 queen take eight
because uh after rook rook
e8 is not i cannot play bishop f7 is
still white is very good
chance to win i think he just missed
bishop c6 idea
yeah his bishop c6 he just think he's
after bishop c6 is black's positions
very good
because now queen d4 is next move and a
4 pawn everything is good bishop is good
but he just missed queenie
but after queen b7 is i think the right
position is near to win
yeah why i need to play just accurately
and i have to say after
a rook to e8 we were looking at you on
the camera and you just
were shaking your head you just couldn't
believe your eyes what was going
because he play very fast and we
all know how lebron is very strong chess
players and his how he's
understand just wearable for me it was a
big surprise why he played
very fast because it's not only a rook
take
it is good i think some move like rook
g1
is just to play back rook and i think so
big problem same
for black i don't need to take it for
good adventure but look here i think
he's winning he's winning yeah he's
winning yeah
look take eight and here his bishop i
don't know
bishop b3 and position is very bad
because no two pawns and first i think
he missed
meeting c5 is like uh queen i don't know
queen take
f4 but queen take a seven queen c1
queen g1 queen b2 but if not queen c5
made the same
black is no pawn uh provide his position
his winning
and now of course is uh this is just
game overall yeah it's always here i
think after bishop if someone is
maybe after the move for his move bishop
nissan's game moves over
do you feel this uh let's say miss is a
byproduct of the fact that
the past one and a half year has been
rapid dress mostly online
no i i think he just missed one move
he played here very good chess levon he
played very nice game against
caron against maxim's every game he he
got good adventure
and he just missed one move absolutely
he
i think after rookie one he think every
move is near to draw
but it is not like it because you need
to play some moves very accurately i
know this position
and i play with black and i think it's
one time i lose for myself also in this
black
and because i think the every move is
drawback is not every movie's draw
check always a pleasure to see you in
tough form thank you very much thank you
for joining us